[Musique]
déclaration surprise du maire de Toronto
vendredi qui annonce sa démission à la
suite de révélation concernant liaison
qui l'entretenait avec une exemployée
que comprendre du geste c'est qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire pour Toronto voyons
voir ce qu'on pense mes collaborateurs
avec assemblées animateur de midi info à
ici première j'entends Hébert et
chroniqueur au Toronto Star et au
magazine d'actualité Michel seoget est
analyste politique à La Presse et
Radio-Canada bon dimanche à vous trois
Bonjour Je vais me tourner vers la
chroniqueur au Toronto Star qu'est-ce
qu'on comprend d'abord c'est votre
journal qui l'a sorti cette histoire-là
vendredi pourquoi pourquoi c'est
important de sortir cette histoire là
d'abord
à savoir est-ce que c'est pertinent
elle travaillait pour lui mais à
travailler plus pour lui etc on est en
2023 il y a deux bonnes raisons quand
même la première c'est une question
d'équité c'est à dire que le Star a été
probablement le journal qui a le plus
déboulonné le maire précédent monsieur
Ford le frère de l'autre et et assez
agressivement et on sait pas retenu pour
publier des histoires mais la deuxième
raison ok à qui était John Tory John
Tory s'est fait élire mère de Toronto en
se présentant comme quelqu'un qui
marchait toujours dans le droit chemin
le côté un peu ennuyant là des fois
qu'on prête à Toronto ou il se passe
rien de grave et ça finit toujours à 8h
du soir il incarnait ça c'était ça sa
marque de commerce donc cette histoire
là va complètement à contresens de sa
marque de commerce c'est comme de dire
je vous ai présenté quelqu'un puis voilà
finalement je suis pas si différente
d'autres moi aussi je suis porté sur les
phrases alors pour ces deux raisons-là
je pense qu'il y avait pas beaucoup de
choix pour le store
cela dit c'est un maire que le Star en
éditorial a appuyé
à la mairie et et c'était aussi un gage
de stabilité John Tory dans le paysage
politique de l'Ontario depuis 40 ans je
l'ai connu à quiz Park jeune conseiller
pour l'ancien Premier ministre Bill
Davis Michel Le connu à Ottawa quand il
travaillait pour Bryan Malone dans son
bureau il s'est présenté comme chef
conservateur candidats Premier ministre
en Ontario et là
c'était son troisième mandat donc il y
en a pas de succession dans le moment
tout le monde se disait pendant les
quatre prochaines années on va trouver
une succession ce qui se prépare à
Toronto c'est une bataille à finir entre
la droite conservatrice et la gauche
progressiste oubliez pas que Monsieur
foire de donner au maire de Toronto le
pouvoir de prendre des décisions même si
seulement un tiers du conseil municipal
la pluie
donc ça prendrait pas grand chose d'un
côté comme de l'autre pour avoir le
contrôle complet j'imagine que Monsieur
Ford à Queen's Park même si je trouvais
que c'était triste pour son ami entre
guillemets qui l'a déjà battu à la
mairie doit se dire qu'il veut vraiment
avoir quelqu'un de la même couleur que
lui à l'Hôtel de Ville moi je disais ce
matin que ça dans les cercles
conservateurs à Toronto ça travaille
fort là ça se prépare avec un mot
là-dessus
ouais
pour donner plus de pouvoir au maire de
Toronto et de ta voix pour diriger des
gens se sont demandés ce qui prépare son
après son après carrière politique aux
provincial lui qui a toujours voulu
d'être mère de Toronto venir avec plus
de pouvoir c'est intéressant
c'est sûr que pour John Tory qu'elle
était à son troisième mandat de
s'accrocher parce qu'il y aurait pu
vouloir s'accrocher parce que Chantal le
dit c'est une relation mutuellement
consentante l'employé n'est plus à son
bureau il y aurait pu faire valoir que
c'est l'histoire ancienne mais en même
temps ça devient une distraction
tellement importante
on lui a toujours questionné est-ce que
vous dites la vérité sur 6 sur ça parce
que vous l'avez pas dit dans le passé
donc rendu un troisième mandat il y
avait peut-être décidé qu'il y avait de
faire le tour du jardin puisqu'elle est
quitter donc la distraction en politique
la perception même si en réalité il y
avait peut-être rien de de d'illégal ou
de condamnable ça devenait ça devenait
difficile de continuer à diriger alors
que les questions ont été comme sur sa
vie privée pendant des semaines des
choses vont être fascinant d'avoir
comment la succession va se préparer on
aura sûrement l'occasion d'en parler je
vous propose d'entendre justement on
parlait de Monsieur Ford le Premier
ministre ontarien on va l'entendre cette
semaine il parlait de santé suivi de
monsieur Legault et on va revenir sur ce
dossier dont on a parlé presque toutes
les semaines l'offre de tawa en matière
de financement de santé ça donne ceci
oui
c'est mon offre c'est final bon je pense
que
on va continuer à dire que ça a pas de
bon sens on va demander plus bon ce qui
va changer d'idée j'espère que le chant
des idées
[Musique]
on va essayer on va essayer mais c'était
pas convaincant il me semble comme comme
argument
d'appeler ça des négociations ça n'est
pas c'est une décision unilatérale du
gouvernement fédéral comme ça toujours
été alors il y a pas de discute il y a
des discussions autant qu'on en veut il
y a pas de discussion qui vont changer
la décision alors ça c'est la première
des choses la deuxième c'est dans la
deuxième phase de ça c'est à dire une
fois qu'on a reçu le chèque puis on dit
le chèque est passé gros qu'est-ce qu'on
fait avec et c'est là-dessus peut-être
que il va y avoir en tout cas au Québec
des discussions intéressantes parce que
Monsieur le mot c'est la première fois
où lui qui a mis son nationalisme très
en avant de même de l'existence de la
coalition du Québec va être obligé de
dire
il y en a pas assez et je ne peux rien
faire ça ça va être il faudra voir
comment les retomber politique vont
arriver pour monsieur Legault mais la
réalité des choses c'est que dans toutes
les les discussions de ce type là à un
moment donné on arrivait avec des
enveloppes du gouvernement en général
qui disait ceci est à prendre ou à
laisser puis c'est arrivé encore une
fois j'entends
le Conseil de la fédération tous les
premiers ministres provinciaux devaient
se rencontrer vendredi là on a repoussé
ça lundi on semble laisser entendre que
ouais on va essayer de voir s'il y a pas
moyen de est-ce qu'il y en a une fenêtre
ou les premiers ministres peuvent
revenir puis dire non non ça nous en
prendre davantage
mais non il y en a pas et de toute façon
entre le ton de Monsieur Ford qui
recevait ses amis du gouvernement
Trudeau la semaine dernière
il y avait tellement content de passer
du temps avec le ministre du clos et
avec Dominique Leblanc il y a ternavel
labrador pince-édouard les premiers
ministres ont passé du temps avec Justin
Trudeau pense à s'entendre je sais pas
si vous avez vu le point de presse de
Daniel Smith la première ministre de
l'Alberta c'était à tel point quand on
mettait bout à bout les déclarations des
premiers ministres plus conservateurs
c'était à se demander ce qu'on leur
avait donné à boire quand il s'était
présenté à la Réunion
à waterwork parce que ça ressemblait
absolument pas autant le sol qui était
dans son ton d'amant puis même c'était à
plus bas c'était François Legault mais
ceci dit le nationalisme de François
Legault et lac en 95 à du référendum
qu'en quantité québécois était au
pouvoir Paul Martin C'est pas gêné pas
pour pas augmenter autant que on aurait
voulu ailleurs qu'on augmente mais pas
diminuer le rythme d'augmentation du
transfert en santé la crise en santé a
commencé là notez la date de ce budget
là 95 6 mois avant le référendum alors
l'idée qu'un premier ministre
souverainiste avec une opinion publique
portée sur le oui aurait obtenu
davantage ben on le fait une fois puis
c'est le contraire qui est arrivé qui
est-ce que tu as moi qui tire le mieux
son épingle du jeu de ces de cet échange
là c'est négociation là puis on sort
comme ça est-ce que tu as droit de
sentir bien les provinces sont très bien
quand même demandé 28 milliards de
dollars par année et il repartent avec
4,6 milliards par année puis 10 bah
finalement c'est pas si mal que ça ou
bien on a mis la barre où on s'est
écrasé trop vite mais c'est pas chic
ceci dit je comprends pourquoi il le
font c'est à dire que dans le cas du
Québec on voulait absolument pas de
normes nationales ou de conditions oui
on voulait plus d'argent on en a un peu
mais la réalité c'est que les finances
publiques du Québec elles ne vont pas si
mal que ça l'inflation est très
importante c'est bon pour le
gouvernement du Québec la formule
actuelle aussi de transfert en santé et
très accroché à l'inflation donc on a
pour deux ou trois ans beaucoup de
transferts en santé qui s'enviennent en
plus des milliards qu'on met sur la
table alors le fait qu'il y a pas de
conditions pas de normes à respecter on
regarde l'enveloppe et on dit ouais on
est capable de vivre avec ça mais on
avait tellement demandé beaucoup que
c'est sûr que tu regardes François
Legault et tu dis ouais on n'est pas
avec grand chose mais la réalité son
ministre des Finances c'est pas
probablement dire François Lego tu sais
je suis capable de m'arranger avec ça là
c'est pour ça que Eric Girard sortait en
disant j'en ai besoin dans le prochain
budget l'important c'est que ça soit
dans le prochain budget parce que je
pense qu'ils sont capables de se
débrouiller avec ça donc il savait
qu'ils avaient qu'ils allaient à la
guerre avec un sling shot en réalité ils
ont tiré leurs roches j'étais Trudeau
dans le front puis elle dit ben ça me
fait pas bouger beaucoup voici la
dernière heure tout le monde est
retourné savoir
il y a peut-être même dit ça me fait pas
vraiment mal c'est une boulette de
papier que j'ai un sondage je pense que
c'est la fin de la semaine qui m'ont
montré qu'une majorité la conséquente le
poste 52% plus élevé que ça pense que
c'est aux province de régler le problème
de la crise en santé 1 et qu'elle
doivent le faire à même leur propre
argent pendant deux ans les premiers
ministres des provinces d'une seule voix
on dit on n'a pas assez d'argent c'est
la faute d'Ottawa et on se retrouve en
bout de piste avec des sondages qui
disent non non non votre problème
occupez vous
c'est un fait mais les premiers
ministres ont quand même tous et
peut-être monsieur le Premier Homme et
tous un problème d'avoir demandé autant
d'avoir reçu aussi peu à un moment donné
il y a une question de rapport de force
là-dedans et ils ont exagéré le rapport
de force qui peut avoir par rapport à
Ottawa on le sait ça arrive à trouver 10
ans alors ils vont avoir à gérer des
retours qui seront pas agréables à cause
de ça
l'idée que en salle de monsieur Legault
on va voir aux prochaines élections
fédérales ça s'adonne que la première
personne qui a répondu présent en disant
cette formule-là me convient totalement
si je deviens Premier ministre s'appelle
Pierre Poillot alors à moins que
François Legault pense que Jack meeting
est en chemin pour le pouvoir parce que
le NPD dit qu'il donnerait 50% de
l'enveloppe de la santé si vous y croyez
vous croyez aussi que dehors il y a des
fleurs dans le jardin mais néanmoins à
moins d'obtenir un gouvernement
majoritaire néo-démocrate le prochain
premier du Canada dans un horizon deux
ou trois ans et partant pour la formule
qui a été proposée mendique
ça fait l'affaire des provinces à faire
l'affaire de l'appareil fédéral un mot
sur Québec solidaire qui est en qui est
en rencontre au sommet cette fin de
semaine pour faire le point sur sa
performance ça peut être performance
durant la dernière élection avec
qu'est-ce qu'on tire là on veut on va se
lancer on va signer le Québec pour
essayer de comprendre pourquoi on
connaît pas avec les Québécois c'est la
bonne façon de faire les choses
oui je pense que c'est la bonne façon de
faire les choses il faut essayer de voir
comment ça se fait qu'à l'extérieur des
centres urbain c'est plus difficile pour
Québec solidaire
faut pas se mentir par exemple c'est
difficile à l'extérieur des centres
urbains pour tous les partis au Québec
sauf la coalition à venir Québec la
partie libérale est décimée en région le
PQ n'a plus de député nulle part sauf
pour la notoriété de Pascal Bérubé et
Johann Arsenault aux îles la Madeleine
ou bien des gens ont voté pour jouer la
sono en espérant que Jonathan Lapierre
demeure mère des yeux de la Madeleine
parce qu'on l'aime aussi alors il y
avait une dynamique régionale très
particulière sinon et alors il y a pas
de député du Bécu non plus mise à part
parce que
à l'extérieur de Montréal donc c'est dur
pour tous les parties c'est dur pour
tous les parties laquaison Québec à rasé
le Québec au complet ce ne sera pas
comme ça éternellement donc aussi bien
se préparer d'aller voir comment ça se
fait que l'image de Québec solidaire
très montréalocentriste Plateau
Mont-Royal quel qui colle aux parties
comment on fait pour dans 4 ans être
capable d'enlever une couche là et
d'être peut-être un peu plus près de ce
que ce qui préoccupe des régions
ressources des idées très bonnes sur le
plan environnemental mais qui passe
moins en région comme taxer les gros
véhicules on sait qu'il y a des cas par
quatre il y en a des pick-up à
l'extérieur de Montréal bon sauf faudra
que ce soit peut-être ajuster mieux
expliquer parce que c'est ce qui
contribue à l'image de Québec solidaire
d'être très montréalais ça veut pas dire
que c'est une mauvaise politique sur
papier ça veut juste dire que c'est
compliqué à vendre à l'extérieur des
centres urbains alors tout ça c'est bien
qu'on le fasse parce qu'on a le temps de
le faire plutôt que de se dire à 6 mois
des élections faudrait qu'on accouche
d'une plateforme trop région non ça ça
se travaille ça se travaille avec le
temps c'est bien qu'on le fasse Michelin
est-ce que les militantes Québec
solidaires sont prêts à ces compromis de
là par exemple sur l'idée du bonus malus
sur les gros véhicules est-ce que les
est-ce qu'ils ont la capacité de dire on
comprend ça va nous permettre de gagner
en région tout ça je ne sais pas il y a
des groupes très radicaux dans Québec
solidaire et là on les voit dans un
conseil général du parti on les voit pas
nécessairement pendant le campagne
électorale alors ça c'est un peu
important d'autre part
le problème Montréal au Centre de Québec
solidaire il est pas facile à régler non
plus parce que c'est des c'est un parti
qui est
urbain par nature et oui on a réussi à
gagner au moins une fois mais ils se
sont fait battre de façon majeure
d'ailleurs à la dernière élection malgré
une excellente députée alors il y a une
difficulté là qui
même tourné en région qui va régler il y
a de l'ouvrage à faire sur le terrain
c'est pas un jugement sur le travail de
l'un ou de l'autre des couchettes de
Québec solidaire mais Manon lancé
Gabriel n'ado Dubois ça fait pas
vraiment d'autres choses comment Réal
comme message et
dans la mesure du possible peut-être
qu'il serait temps que solidaire
commence à penser à des monsaliser
une partie de sa direction pour se
donner des racines en région parce que
autrement ça donne toujours l'impression
qu'ils sont en visite quand ils vont en
région ce genre de tourné là ça confirme
un peu cette impression là il faut qu'on
aille en visite pour découvrir le Québec
et s'enraciner pas sûr que ça soit
nécessairement un message qui va être
supporteur que ça ce serait intéressant
de passer la main effectivement ça ça va
être intéressant à surveiller c'est tout
le temps qu'on a merci d'avoir été là ce
matin on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine
au revoir